bei mir der mann bekannt aus funk und
fernsehen bisher und jetzt auch aus dem
ministersessel gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach herr lauterbach wir haben
wirklich schwierige zeiten hand aufs
herz wie hart wird diese corona
weihnacht und dieses corona silvester
für deutschland
vielen artikeln für die gelegenheit es
kommt sehr darauf an was uns jetzt in
den nächsten wochen noch gelingt also
wenn es uns gelingt die maßnahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes also dieses
großen gesetzes womit wir also kontakt
herunterfahren können ungeimpfte
schützen können wenn wir diese maßnahmen
umsetzen und wir sind bei der booster
impfung so erfolgreich wie in den
letzten tagen wo wir sehr erfolgreich
gewesen sind und sind vorsichtig bei den
reisen dann glaube ich kann das
weihnachtsfest gelingen ohne dass wir
uns gefährdet und wenn nicht naja dann
ist es eben so dass wir andere maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen wenn tatsächlich diese
wertvolle maßnahmen die heute der
deutsche bundestag beschlossen hat nicht
umgesetzt werden oder nicht kontrolliert
dann werden wir auf der anderen seite
einschenken müssen im sinne zu tun
zumindest empfehlungen wer wen noch zu
weihnachten besuchen kann und das will
ja niemand wir können das schaffen also
es droht eine einsame weihnacht aber sie
muss nicht sein ich glaube nicht dass er
nach einer 1 sonne war nach droht dem
sinne dass sie wahrscheinlich ist
sondern also ich glaube dass wir es
hinbekommen
die länder müssen jetzt kämpfen die
maßnahmen beschlossen worden sind müssen
auch umgesetzt werden und kontrolliert
werden wenn wir das machen und es wird
viel getestet vorher wir sind den
schulen besonders vorsichtig masken
werden getragen
bevorzugt es würde jeden tag getestet in
den tagen vor den feiertagen dann also
kann man mit einem viel besseren gefühl
und auch mit mir viel mehr sicherheit
die weihnachtstage beginnt also zarte
hoffnung für weihnachten und für
silvester aber sie sind jetzt wenn alles
gut läuft für sie vier jahre unser
gesundheitsminister wird in ihrer
amtszeit corona besiegt werden corner
ganz zu besiegen wird uns über die
absehbare
periode vier jahren nicht gelingen da
muss man realistisch sein wir haben die
situation dass es immer wieder also
varianten geben wird die varianten
entstehen oft den menschen die
immunschwäche haben die
autoimmunerkrankung haben die krebse
hand halten haben also also diese also
varianten gehen erstmal weiter das muss
man realistischerweise zu sehen was
unser ziel aber sagen kann ist dass wir
ein so dichtes und gutes impfangebot
genutzt haben das selbst bei neuen
varianten so gut wie keine gefahr
besteht und dass ich nicht weiter
ausbreitet daran muss man arbeiten das
ist ein realistisches ziel und dann also
arbeite ich schon seit der stunde 1 seit
ich das ministerium betreten habe ich
schon vorm an der vereidigung die
regierung will das war noch ein
versprechen der alten bundesregierung
aber olaf scholz und auch die halbe
ampel saßen ja da schon mit am tisch bis
heiligabend 30 millionen deutsche
durchgeimpft haben stand heute schaffen
sie das
zumal das ja nicht eine einzelleistung
von mir ich bin zwar im harz der titel
aber ich empfinde ich den dieses volumen
wir haben 14 14 eineinhalb millionen
impfungen hinter uns jetzt sind so diese
tage also bis weihnachten natürlich also
zu nutzen wir haben jetzt auch erreicht
also dass am wochenende stark geimpft er
hat ich möchte mich bei der gelegenheit
auch bedanken bei den ärztinnen und
ärzten die jetzt wirklich mit voller
kraft auch am wochenende eben wir haben
1,1 millionen impfungen vor zwei tagen
gab das ist ein rekord von daher ich bin
da optimistisch obwohl die 30 millionen
ganz schaffen das war sich nicht das
wird sich zeigen wenn nicht wird es auf
jeden fall nicht am impfstoff schaltern
der impfstoff ist für dieses ziel da
also karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister gibt das impfstoff
fall sprechen dass sie entspannt auch
schon jemand das geben sie auch wir
haben genügend ampullen bis weihnachten
oder bis zum jahresende das ist
das habe ich präzise geprüft da bin ich
auch mit den abteilungen sofort
eingestiegen ich habe auch schon
impfstoff bestellt um zu lernen wie man
das genau macht aber wie gesagt bis zum
jahresende ist der impfstoff gut sie
haben im juli noch eine allgemeine
impfpflicht also eine impfpflicht für
alle deutschen ausgeschlossen jetzt soll
sie doch kommt warum diese krasse
kehrtwende wie erklären sie die den
deutschen medizin ist natürlich also
einem arzt muss wenn die diagnose sich
verändert hat die therapie verändern was
hat sich verändert hat die data variante
ist mit voller wucht durch gelaufen und
wir befürchten jetzt die uniqa und
variante das heißt also der wert dieser
re produktionswert der für die frage
brauchen wir eine nebenpflicht ja oder
nein so entscheidend ist das hängt den
wesentlichen mehrwert er ist jetzt so
hoch wir nähern uns jetzt mittlerweile
also der also situation die wir bei
nasen und bei windpocken haben was sie
vertrat aber sozusagen die ansteckung
angeht und natürlich ist cola viel
gefährlicher das ist klar von daher also
mit dem neuen mit neuen varianten ist
nicht notwendig das war damals noch
nicht so klar die impfpflicht wirklich
heftig und hart diskutiert wir haben
jetzt schon wirklich also freundschaften
zerbrechen familien sind in der umfrage
in der kroner frage gespalten wir sehen
fackelzüge die zu den privathäusern von
politiker gehen wissenschaftler werden
bedroht befürchten sie nicht dass die
impfpflicht genau in diesem klima
wirklich zum gesellschaftlichen
brandbeschleuniger wird also dazu seien
möglicherweise wird das so sein also ich
bin auch selbst betroffen also erst
letzten acht ist mein büro
also in köln opfer geworden um eine
privatwohnung auch schon häufiger und so
weiter ich kenne das und nicht desto
trotz wir können als staat in einer so
wichtigen frage wie wir die bevölkerung
vor einer schweren erkrankung schützen
können wir uns nicht erpressen lassen
das wird nicht möglich sein das wollen
wir nicht ich werde das auf jeden fall
nicht mittragen wollen wir müssen für
diejenigen die hier gefährdet sind
schwer zu erkranken müssen wir kämpfen
und da kann es nicht sagen dass eine
gewaltbereite minderheit glaubt uns
erpressen zu können das kann nicht
stattfindet wenn diese im pflicht kommt
was macht ein karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister über solche fragen
denke ich nicht nach also die
impfpflicht also wird ja vom deutschen
bundestag beschlossen und ob sie kommt
oder nicht das weiß ich tatsächlich
nicht ich bin ein klarer befürworter der
allgemeine impfpflicht
da lege ich mich schon fest aber als
abgeordnete ich sage ich mache diese
unterscheidungen weil als minister wird
es also mir nicht erlaubt sein eine
impfpflicht zu bringen das ist keine
also regierungsentscheidung sondern
ihren schaden das parlament das ist eine
gewissensentscheidung und diese
gewissensentscheidung das hatte übrigens
justizminister buschmann vorgeschlagen
dass der richtige vorschlag diese
gewissensentscheidung
sie wird hoffentlich so ausfallen dass
wir die impfpflicht bekommen sicher ist
man natürlich nicht sie sind dafür
möglichst viele kinder zu impfen aber
macht es deutlich mehr sinn eine
impfpflicht zudem pflicht zu machen
führt lehrer und für erzieher und für
alle die an den schulen und in den kitas
arbeiten statt schulkinder unter druck
zu setzen
schulkinder werden nicht unter druck ist
jetzt also
weder vom ersten noch vom lehrpersonal
noch von den eltern also schulkinder
entscheiden sich für die impfung oder
oder nicht und sie werden auch nicht
geimpft von uns im herzen ich sage es
mal was eben was wenn sie das nicht
wollen kein ebenfalls oder kein
niedergelassener arzt impft ein kind
wenn das kind sagt ich will das nicht
somit also das ganz klar muss damit kein
falscher eindruck entsteht aber hier ist
noch die frage was ist gefährlicher für
die kinder die erkrankung oder die
impfung und da ist ganz klar wir kranken
ist gefährlicher und bei der omicron
variante zeigen die ersten wichtigen
auswerten aus südafrika in die richtung
dass es dort besonders gelten können wie
gefährlich ist um die grund entstand
heute man kann doch nicht alles sagen
aber stand heute wie gefährlich ist die
omikron variante und vor allem für wien
die schnelle antwort da ist wir wissen
dass noch nicht wir wissen dass omikron
deutlich ansteckender ist wir wissen
dass omikron auch diejenigen befällt die
schon einmal infiziert waren ja auch
diejenigen die schon zwei mal infiziert
waren haben werden südafrika menschen
gesehen und wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass sind aber jetzt labordaten im
wesentlichen aber sehr gute laborstudien
die da gemacht worden sind da muss man
davon ausgehen dass also die impfungen
ohne booster impfung wahrscheinlich hier
nicht ausreichen werden das ist das was
wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wissen über
den über die schwere der erkrankung
wissen wir noch sehr wenig
können sie uns sagen
wie oft sich die deutschen jetzt in
zukunft impfen lassen müssen also erst
hieß es ein jahr lang doppel impfung
reicht reicht ausland diese nach dem
halben jahr jetzt doch noch mal pusten
lassen dann verkürzt sich der zeitraum
fünf monate jetzt wird es noch mal
kürzer also hand aufs herz stand heute
immer stand heute wie oft müssen wir
impfen gehen und wie lange gilt dem
zertifikat
wie oft wir uns impfen lassen müssen
wissen wir noch nicht wenn die omikron
variante kommt ist wahrscheinlich der
impfschutz nur
vollständig wenn man drei mal geimpft
war auch bei der delta variante nimmt
nach vier monaten nach der zweiten
impfung der impfschutz im sinne dass man
sich infizieren kann schon sehr deutlich
ab somit also kann es sein dass wir also
drei impfungen brauchen
waren dann eine weitere impfung
notwendig ist das wissen wenn ich das
wird sehr stark davon abhängen wie ich
wär man bei omikron erkrankt das wissen
wir noch nicht und ob es weitere
varianten gibt also peter titel der sich
morgen boostern lässt dem kann sich
jetzt noch nicht sagen kapitel sie
müssen in drei monaten wieder hin oder
in vier monaten oder können sie die
empfehlungen geben nein diese empfehlung
zu geben wäre jetzt völlig unseriös die
daten die wir dafür benötigen
hier habe ich nicht sie haben sich
eingeschaltet damals auch in die debatte
um den bayern münchen fußball profi
joshua king der sich nicht impfen lassen
wollte der leidet jetzt doch stärker
unter den nachwirkungen einer krone
erkrankung die ihn dann erwischt hat er
fällt mindestens bis zum bis zum
jahresende aus sind menschen wie joshua
kimmig oder schwer erkrankte die
ungeimpft auf den also die ungeimpft
waren und die schwer erkrankt und jetzt
auf intensivstation mit corona liegen
sind die am ende des tages selber schuld
das würde ich nicht sagen also das würde
ich sagen ich habe also
da ich bin ja auch in kontakt mit hansi
flick gewesen in der angelegenheit
fußball nationaltrainer im fußball
nationaltrainer und also ich glaube das
ist falsch ist also hier vorwürfe zu
machen das ist nicht richtig
ich glaube dass auch so ein fußballer
das also für sich entscheiden muss für
so ein fußballer ist der körper ja also
das kann man sagen mehr oder weniger
wichtigste kapital und er hat sich halt
anders entschieden ich hätte mir
gewünscht es sich impfen lassen ich
hoffe dass er wieder vollständig gesund
wird und im
nationalteam wirklich also die leistung
wieder abrufen kann die ja immer abrufen
konnte aber so ein fall zeigt natürlich
also wie gefährlich die infektion ist
denn das ist ja jemand der voll durch
dann jedes der kerngesundes und trotzdem
ist das kein pappenstiel wenn jemand wie
joshua kinder
erkrankt wir sind gefährlicher in einem
raum ein durch geimpfter der sich dort
zwei wochen lang nicht hat testen lassen
oder ein nicht geimpfter der sich
regelmäßig vielleicht sogar täglich
testen ist also man muss ja unter
schaden gefährlich für andere und so ob
es gefährlich für ihn ist für andere und
dass ich würde aber trotzdem immer damit
anfangen wie gefährdet ist derjenige der
um games ist ist natürlich also gerade
damit entscheidet ja selbst präsent sein
risiko für die anderen egal also ganz so
einfach ist es dann nicht also wenn er
sich infiziert dann also ist es nicht
eine reine privatsache weil er kann zum
beispiel sehr schwer erkranken sehr
schwer erkranken und nimmt dann anderen
wiederum das intensiv bett weg wo jemand
mit einem schlaganfall nicht behandelt
werden kann somit ist das keine
kleinigkeit oder infiziert noch andere
somit noch so kann man nicht sagen auch
für den ungeimpften also internationale
situationen wie der jetzige personal aus
meiner sicht auch so aber sicherlich
keine privatsache ist keine privatsache
und es ist richtig dass der so geehrte
auch infiziert sein kann und andere
infiziert aber die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass er infiziert ist ist viel geringer
ok es gab eine irritation über einen
satz den sie gestern bei maybrit illner
gesagt hat da haben sie sinngemäß gesagt
sie hat mit dafür gesorgt dass ein
artikel der bild und der für aufsehen
gesorgt hat dass der das tier
verschwunden ist könnte ganz kurz
aufklärung schaffen ja ich will nicht da
also aus der schule plaudern aber es war
ja so also hier wurden drei
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
quasi als die verursacher des
weihnachtsmarktes bezeichnen das war
einfach fahrlässig das kann man so nicht
handhaben der artikel war daher schlecht
aus meiner sich erstens stimmt es nicht
dass sind wissenschaftler die politik
das machen wir und zum zweiten die leute
werden dann ja quasi vor also vors tor
geschoben und das hat er noch wehgetan
und von daher habe ich mich da
eingesetzt bei ihnen in dem blatt dass
der artikel von der homepage verzichtet
über details möchte ich aber hier nicht
mehr richtig ist aber nicht verschwunden
der artikel der artikel ist nach wie vor
da sind das muss man feststellen gut
sind jetzt dabei was glauben sie
eigentlich was war schon der kurze
nachfrage der artikel ist auf der
homepage der bild -zeitung weiter zu
sehen sind das rechnet man kann hier
finden klar so ganz was aber was war für
sie schwieriger oder was glauben sie was
da für olaf scholz schwieriger die
koalitionsverhandlungen mit der fdp und
den grünen oder karl lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister zu verkaufen also
müssen sie olaf scholz fragen aber was
sie glauben also ich glaube sagt über
glauben werde ich hier nicht noch zum
schluss etwas sagen ich kann aber sagen
dass eigentlich arbeite sehr also
intensiv und gerne mit olaf scholz
zusammen wir kennen uns sehr lange und
von daher ist es eine gute
zusammenarbeit und also daran wird
definitiv an unserer guten
zusammenarbeit dann wird niemand rühren
sie sind ja nicht nur bekannt aus funk
und fernsehen sondern sie sind ja auch
bekannt von twitter und aus und hält aus
diesen talkshows also karl lauterbach
weiter munter twittern auch nachts und
vor allem selber und haben sie sich eine
talkshow diät auferlegt ich werde
weiterhin auch ab und zu in talkshows
seien insbesondere dann wenn ich glaube
dass ich also eine also botschaft für
die bevölkerung
habe die möglicherweise helfen kann dass
wir uns so verhalten dass man es nicht
gegenseitig gefährden also wenn ich
glaube dass ich tatsächlich einen
inhaltlichen punkt also zu setzen habe
danke ich auch in talkshows das wird
etwas weniger werden aber die inhalte
die für die ich stehe und kämpfe die
werde ich nicht nur in talkshows aber
die werde ich auch weiter kommunizieren
und twitter werde ich weniger machen
können leider weil also tatsächlich ist
so ein bisschen die zeit die studien zu
lesen zurück geht aber wir haben ja
jetzt einen großartigen experten hart
und werde dann für sie ein bisschen also
studienarbeit ist nach wie vor möglich
von daher wird das geschäft ich ganz
ändern es wird weitergehen der erste
anruf als sie erfahren haben dass die
minister werden an wen gegen der das
will ich nicht erzählen gut an an
jemanden den ich sehr schätze aber dass
das bewahrt und man hat ihre mutter
davon erfahren meine mutter hat sehr
schnell davon erfahren als essayist ja
mit fast 87 jahren ist sehr politisch
interessiert und also verfolgt auch
meine arbeit tätig und von daher hat sie
sehr schnell erfahren sie galt meister
herr der fliegen sie haben jetzt 100
fliegen das war ein markenzeichen für
ingolstadt statt schlips jetzt haben sie
keine flieger und kein schlips kommt ein
schlips oder kommt eine fliege ich hoffe
ich komme ganz ohne aus aber ich habe
die kollegen tatsächlich versteigert da
hat ein privat fernseher sogar geholfen
dazu gegeben also für wohltätige zwecke
sind die pflegen versteigert worden
damit alle aber fehler sie haben vorhin
gesagt dass sie mich noch mal kurz auf
die angriffe zurück kommt die momentan
stattfinden ich habe vorhin gesagt auch
ihr büro wo opfer ich weiß von einem
befreundeten fernsehteam das ist
natürlich auch probleme gab das nur und
das quasi unter polizeischutz auch an
das interview beendet werden werden
konnte können sie erzählen was in dem
büro vorgefallen ist oder an ihrem büro
und in ihrer wohnung ach das ist also
ich möchte es einfach nicht erzählen um
nicht noch anderen also hier hinweise zu
geben aber ich bin halt tatsächlich im
brennpunkt der debatte also das ist klar
dass damit muss ich auch leben
aber ich versichere ihnen das ist nicht
mal größte sorge ich bin gut geschützt
und also ich finde es furchtbar solche
menschen gibt die also in ihrer
wahrscheinlich ja auch zum teil selbst
gerechtigkeit andere bedrohen aber hier
geht es nicht um mich ich empfehle ich
erfahre mich als sehr gut geschützt und
komme damit gut klar das wird meine
arbeit nicht beeinträchtigen die letzte
frage herr lauterbach man sie nur
weihnachtsbotschaft an die deutschen
wenden können was wäre die die
weihnachtsbotschaft wäre wirklich dass
man sich vor der abreise zum
weihnachtsfest oder wenn man sich auch
privat zu hause dass man sich wirklich
gut testet ein paar tage test oder so
und die testen am sichersten wenn man
die tests ein paar tage hintereinander
nach wenn man dann so miteinander feiert
dann also ist man im sicheren bereich
aber dann begegnet man sich also wie
sich menschen begegnen sollten die
sich führen da kümmern vielen dank und
mit diesen antrag wollen worten vom
neuen gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach gebe ich zurück zu euch ins
studium